l'uomo ha sempre
di lasciare una traccia della propria
testimonianza fino sin dai tempi remoti
e utilizzava appunto i graffiti graffiti
per raccontare per parlare appunto la
caccia la costruzione delle case e gli
incontri con altre popolazioni con altri
la scoperta di altri animali e dopo i
graffiti c'è stato un evoluzione
nell'antico egitto che il disegno è
diventato appunto una forma di scrittura
è una forma di scrittura vera propria
usavano appunto dei disegni che per come
come dei simboli di lettere
dopodiché con man mano che l'uomo si
diciamo si evolveva ha inventato l'arte
l'arte è diventata comunque sia un mezzo
di comunicazione per esprimere se stesso
per per lasciare comunque sia un
messaggio alle generazioni che verranno
dopo
grazie appunto mamma grazie appunto
l'arte man mano che l'uomo andava avanti
venivano inventate nuove tecniche di
disegno tra cui il graphic journalism
che è una tecnica di fumetto è una
specie di parola disegno e soprattutto
realtà raccontare la realtà attraverso
appunto sia a livello visivo che a
livello di parola di attraverso questo
c'è una storia dietro al graphic
journalism e con la mia esperienza non
so se avete mai visto un fumetto in cui
la protagonista è una ragazza che porta
il velo una ragazza che ha vissuto
comunque si è che vive soprattutto negli
ultimi anni una una battaglia
giornaliera una diciamo una battaglia di
integrazione con una integrazione per
per dire per far vedere comunque sia
perché per lasciare una testimonianza di
quello che è realmente realmente il velo
per superare lo scoglio di quello che i
media li hanno associato ecco vi
racconto una storia diciamo la mia
storia dall'inizio fino ad oggi
io sono una ragazza che ha vissuto nel
deserto nel sud della tunisia
diciamo che ho vissuto sotto sotto una
dittatura sotto una forte pressione da
parte del governo del governo che c'era
fino a qualche anno fa e appunto perché
la mia famiglia è stata molto molto
attiva
una una delle famiglie che comunque
erano oppositori ecco che richiedevano
comunque sia la libertà di pensiero alla
libertà di parola soprattutto e la
libertà religiosa
diciamo che è superato appunto come
dicevo prima lo scoglio della mia vita
in tunisia all'età di otto anni mi sono
rifugiata con la famiglia con la mia
famiglia qui in italia è però portando
sempre con me questo sogno superato
superato l'oppressione c'è stato un
forte cambiamento per me in italia e il
cambiamento della lingua e della scuola
dei compagni di scuola non sapevo
parlare italiano quindi dovevo adattarmi
in qualche modo dovevo adattarmi quindi
cominciato a disegnare in classe poi
superato e diciamo anche questa fase
dell'integrazione e ho deciso di mettere
il velo di mettere il velo perché era
appunto nel 2001 2002 era diciamo un
periodo periodo storico abbastanza
importante uscivo con le miserie le più
grandi io sono la sesta di sette figli
uscivo con le mie sorelle più grandi che
loro già lo portavano ero molto più
grandi di me vedevo comunque che
venivano guardati che tutti i riflettori
erano puntati su di loro venivano
guardati in un modo un po io non capivo
cosa succedeva non capivo quindi vedremo
questa cosa mi ero curiosità molto
provato un giorno detto oggi lo metto
anch'io voglio vedere se succede la
stessa cosa anche a me l'ho portato con
me sto era nel 2002 e nel giro di
qualche ora è capitato la stessa cosa in
camice quindi da lì è partita tutta la
mia la mia fase creativa
ho cominciato a disegnare ragazzi che
portano il velo cominciato a disegnare
appunto dar loro una storia ha
cominciato a raccontare la mia storia
attraverso queste ragazze
a fumetto è
dopodiché vabbè ho fatto ho fatto molte
ricerche molte ricerche in senso che
provavo a chiedere in giro nonostante la
mia giovanissima età aveva 11 anni 12
anni e avendo appunto molte risposte
tutte le risposte che cercavo e
ho cominciato a fare ad essere attivo
anche a livello di associazioni e
organizzazioni umanitarie e che comunque
diciamo oltre al livello a livello
organizzativo mettevo facevo queste
storie scrivo queste storie e li mettevo
in mostra in questi eventi vedevo che
comunque sia interessavano molto alla
gente perché chi frequentava questo
ambiente
sapeva di cosa parlavano sapeva e molti
dei quali si sentivano parte della
storia perché hanno vissuto anche loro
la diciamo l'esperienza come la mia
soprattutto a livello a livello e
soprattutto chi frequenta le asl le
organizzazioni umanitarie di
volontariato che vi comunque ho
conosciuto molti molti molti siriani
molti
tunisini molti diciamo provenienti da
tutte le parti del mondo che anche loro
hanno vissuto un'esperienza oltre a
quella che è stata la mia in tunisia ma
anche a livello di associazioni
giovanili
in italia e avevano comunque sia uno
questo questo questa difficoltà ad
integrarsi ecco soprattutto per quanto
riguarda le ragazze perché il velo è
diventato c'è un ragazzo non si vede
come sommano ma una ragazza se una
ragazza che porta al vero si vede c'è
anche chi non la conosce si vede che
volevano anche loro comunque sia
raccontare questa cosa
le persone lì ero piccola le persone
diciamo perché non scrivi la mia storia
di qua io mi ero abbastanza diciamo
interessato a questa cosa e piano piano
sono arrivata ai media ai media in senso
i giornalisti che partecipavano a questi
eventi si interessavano molto alle ai
fumetti che scrivevo è poi allargato
diciamo allargato e le tematiche a
livello politico a livello
diciamo umanitario raccontato anche
diverse diverse storie su sulle guerre
su salling sul razzismo ma non dal
solamente dal mio punto di vista ma
anche dall'altro lato perché ci sta
anche il razzismo all'incontrario come
si dice
per me comunque la matita la matita uno
strumento molto molto importante e molto
diciamo è un mezzo di comunicazione
molto importante e può essere e lo è il
mezzo di integrazione efficace